welcome back the new year brings in a
couple of new laws and that's the topic
of today's la vegas now segment with
eric palacios
eric we have a brand new year and
sometimes that can mean
new laws are there any noteworthy laws
that are coming into effect
in 2021 that's a great question and
the legislature meets every two years in
nevada
five years so the last session was 2019
which means most of the laws and changes
they enacted went into effect
uh in 2020. however there were some that
because of the
uh difficulty of enacting them or
changes that needed to come about
are going into effect uh this month uh
2021.
okay and what are those that we can look
out for the two main ones that affect us
here in clark county uh one
is there are more judges in place there
are six new positions
that have been uh opened up uh most of
them in family court which means
that family law cases uh will move
forward
uh quicker and more efficiently so
that's great news for us
uh the other one uh the other change is
uh
folks that work in the convention
industry and trade shows
uh because of the this the size and
the the quickness that they have to put
together these stages
and take them apart the setups for the
conventions
they are going to have to take 10 hours
of health and safety training
per year supervisors are going to have
to take 30 hours
of safety and health training so this
will hopefully
help everyone stay safer that works in
conventions and trade shows
well what's interesting about that that
was passed before covet came into play
it was it was at the last legislative
session in 2019
however because there had to be time to
uh
put together the the the schooling the
classes and everything
uh they delayed the enforcement of it
until
uh 2021 and this year we'll see the
legislature get together again and
hopefully
uh we'll see the changes uh soon after
that and with the judges i understand
there's
still a backlog of cases not only in
family court but in all the courts right
now
because of kovitt exactly there's a huge
backlog uh judges and the court system
has been great and trying to move things
forward
but there are a lot of things that need
to be in person and that are sensitive
that way
so there's a lot of hearings a lot of
trials that we're not able to continue
uh also there's a lot of stacking of
certain types of
cases for instance uh evictions those
have been put on hold
for months and months so once uh they
open up again
soon we're going to see a huge backlog
in that department
all right eric always good to talk to
you thanks so much for joining us
thanks for having me for more
information you can give eric palacios
and associates a call that phone number
702-444-7777